welcome to the newshour live from london
coming up in the next 60 minutes
as many as 60 reported dead after a
double bomb attack outside outside kabul
airport where thousands were still
gathered hoping to escape the country
among those killed a number of children
and 12 american service personnel
but the u.s and uk are continuing to
airlift people out but several other
countries have stopped their evacuations
early
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program well
medical sources in afghanistan have told
al jazeera that as many as 60 people
were killed in two explosions outside
kabul's international airport the
pentagon is saying the attack was
carried out by two suicide bombers and
killed 12 u.s service personnel a number
of children are also thought to have
died the taliban has condemned the
attacks which came hours after the u.s
uk and australia warned people to stay
away from the airport because of an
imminent threat from an isil affiliate
hours after the attack the group claimed
responsibility ahmed karzai
international airport in kabul is where
thousands of people have been gathering
hoping to flee afghanistan western
countries have been using the airport to
evacuate their citizens troops and
afghan allies the u.s and uk are
continuing their evacuation flights
until that august 31st deadline to
withdraw all foreign troops but germany
denmark belgium and canada have now
ended their evacuations and france says
its last plane will leave on friday
charles stratford reports now from kabul
[Music]
ambulances rush through the streets to
collect the wounded bodies are lifted
onto stretchers
the two attacks by suicide bombers
happened close to the abbey gate
entrance of kabul airport near the baron
hotel
there was a sudden explosion we climbed
out and saw that there were many people
affected people were hurled everywhere
their brains were scattered there were
also foreign forces who were falling
i saw at least four or 500 people there
the explosion was really powerful half
were hurled into the water others on the
ground outside we carried the wounded
here on stretchers and here my clothes
are completely bloody
the baron hotel is controlled by the uk
and nato forces it is one of the places
where tens of thousands of afghans have
been gathering after the taliban took
control of kabul on august the 15th
they've been going there to have their
papers processed before being evacuated
out of the country
western governments and security experts
in kabul had been warning about
potential attacks around the airport for
days
the taliban told al jazeera it had
intelligence about potential car bombs
in the area and also warned people to
stay away
an increasing number of nato countries
have already announced a halt to their
evacuation operations
and these attacks jeopardize remaining
flights meaning many afghans who want to
leave their country and may have all the
necessary documents to do so could be
left behind
the taliban have condemned the attacks
and vowed to bring the perpetrators to
justice but suicide bombings like these
not dissimilar to those that the taliban
used against what it often described as
foreign invaders
show just the kind of security
challenges the movement faces
charles stratford al jazeera kabul
well rob mcbride joins us live from
kabul and obviously it's been an
incredibly difficult day rob and that
was followed by uh reports of another
explosion but uh give us the latest
information on that and what's been
happening in the afghan capital since
the airport attacks
yeah it has been an incredibly uh tense
thursday night going through into what
is now a friday morning here uh local
time it really has raised the the
tension level the sense of unease uh
really the whole of kabul now on edge
we're seeing a lot more checkpoints
around kabul uh with the taliban
stopping vehicles at different street
corners etc uh we've heard occasional
gunshots in the street uh you do get a
sense that the taliban
are really a sort of a heightened uh
awareness of now of the the security
situation are quite skittish
about what's going on across from the
airport we can still hear the occasional
uh volley of gunfire automatic gunfire i
think i saw earlier on a bit of tracer
going up into the night sky
and then the occasional thud and crump
we've heard a couple of explosions now
it's not clear exactly what these
explosions uh have been it's understood
that if there have been further attacks
we would have had more details about the
what kind of attacks they were and we
haven't had those yet so it could well
be that this is uh simply military units
either uh u.s forces coalition forces or
possibly some of their afghan special
forces allies who are also out there at
the airport offering uh protection of
the perimeter possibly destroying
equipment or something of a
that has an intelligence value in
preparation for the ultimate evacuation
we've been hearing other noises during
the evening all the way through thursday
night now friday morning overhead we
hear uh military jets presumably
american military jets circling uh
then also the lower rumble of aircraft
of transport aircraft taking off from
hamidkarzai international airport as
this evacuation uh continues a pace with
they you hear them constantly taking off
either c-17s or c-130s different types
of transport aircraft
we know that with the the uptick in
violence and all the warnings of isis
attacks that has prompted a number of
countries such as hungary poland belgium
the netherlands all to draw their
evacuations to a close uh sometimes
prematurely uh but having got most of
the their nationals out and that really
leaves the united states as as the the
main stakeholder if you like in this
evacuation exercise still evacuating its
people but after the the attacks that
we've seen thursday night really having
to address just how it goes about
continuing with that exercise whether it
brings forward
it's it's closing of the evacuation
operation or whether it extends it
beyond there we heard from the u.s
military before about whether it brings
in more forces or tries to extend the
perimeter further out to try to prevent
more attacks like this and we heard from
the u.s military that there are no plans
at the moment to put more boots on the
ground bring in more u.s personnel but
it does remain to be seen just how
they're going to try and deal with this
deteriorating security situation the
increased threat from
organizations like islamic state here
in afghanistan
as they continue to try to finish their
operation by the 31st of august that is
midnight tuesday
you know rob it's worth mentioning that
uh even before
the u.s withdrawal from afghanistan and
indeed the taliban taker of the takeover
of the country this was not uh
kabul had seen increasing violence and
instability actually over a number of
years we're talking about a campaign of
assassinations against a civil society
activists and journalists and others and
then
horrific explosions at a maternity
hospital and a school uh
a school for um hazara girls
is there a sense now that the the
presence of
is in afghanistan is is growing that
it's becoming stronger
that i guess is going to be the worry
you know the previous administration of
ashraf ghani when it was backed by the
u.s forces especially with its air power
it really did take on islamic state
there was a real concern that as islamic
state was being pounded in parts of the
middle east it was being shrunk in syria
and iraq
that it was ascending fighters or it was
starting to put lay down routes in
afghanistan in particular in eastern
afghanistan and around 2018 2019 uh the
the the government of the then
government of afghanistan supported by
u.s forces and in particular us air
power really did target them and really
pounded them in their strongholds in the
east of the country and it was thought
at one point that they'd pretty much
been defeated islamic state apart from a
few pockets
of resistance but you know that was at a
time when you had a stronger more
confident uh afghan government backed up
of course by far more american air power
american military might all of that has
now gone you have a taliban that is
feeling its way into this government
that it's suddenly found itself
inheriting it has a country to run it
has myriad problems uh of just uh
governing the country
regardless of trying to maintain
security security
is one of its uh
one of its priorities it has said that
from the start it has to secure the
country the situation around the country
it has been doing that we've seen that
in kabul with all of its checkpoints and
roadblocks trying to disarm different
groups
or militias etc that so that it remains
the uh the sole
power of the sole military force in the
country but it does have of course
rivals like islamic state and it does
islamic state has managed to
re-establish itself uh somewhat and it
remains to be seen just what kind of a
relationship the taliban is going to uh
strike with this organization because on
the one hand it it wants nothing to do
with islamic state it said that it
regards it as a rival
but at the other on the other hand in
some of the provinces at local level
there is some indication that it isn't
as clear-cut as that that taliban small
taliban units may have been working with
islamic states so it remains to be seen
just how uh the taliban asserts it off
its authority and how it deals with
islamic state
the organization itself isis it probably
the the suspicion would be that it's
going to have to keep a low profile it
knows that it's in a a tricky situation
with the taliban that if it wants to
maintain its operations and not become a
target for for the taliban to be swept
out of afghanistan immediately then it
is going to have to uh
going to have to curtail some of its
operations and attacks having said that
with the
operations that are going on at the
international airport just a few
kilometers away with the presence of
international forces of american
soldiers who it is sworn to attack
wherever and whenever it can it seems
like it was it has been and is too good
a target for isis to miss it was bound
almost to launch this attack and the
fear is that it's going to launch more
of these attacks we had earlier this
week warnings that isis could be
planning something and in the last 24 36
hours we had repeated warnings from
multiple sources different governments
their intelligence agencies militaries
and from the taliban themselves all of
them were saying the same story that
isis was planning
attacks against
the airport
which is a very
vulnerable target because of the
confusion there the chaos you have
thousands of people milling around the
airport perimeter all dressed in
civilian clothes all carrying bags it's
the perfect cover for suicide bombers to
mingle in there and the taliban has said
we
said it has made uh efforts to try to
stop this kind of attack at the the u.s
military in their press briefing
thursday night uh corroborated that they
said that they the taliban has set up
roadblocks it has tried to uh search
people but it is patchy and people will
get will get through uh and that's what
we've seen and the the danger is uh that
because uh it was uh because the
predictions of this attack were so
widespread and so universal there is
also concern of future attacks and we're
hearing for example both from the us
intelligence and the taliban that
there's the possibility of bigger
attacks involving car bombs which is
obviously of a far more serious concern
not only for
u.s forces and its coalition partners at
the airport but also for the taliban not
only there but also at other potential
targets now looking around the city of
kabul itself thank you for now rob
mcbride bringing us all the latest from
the afghan capital kabul thank you rob
well the pentagon has warned that more
attacks are expected